so far we are not seeing that GOP surge
that many Republicans have forecasted
with five races still to call it's
unclear who will control the Senate
you've got Nevada Arizona Wisconsin
Georgia and Alaska still do not have a
winner at this hour control of the house
is leaning Republican but only barely
Democrats overall are doing much better
than expected our chief election and
campaign correspondent that's Robert
Costas following all of this Bob good
morning to you politics never gets old
does it it does not Gail good morning
this was not the night most Republicans
expected their hope for big red wave
that never materialized the GOP May yet
win control of the house but the Senate
still up for grabs after several key
races went blue
I'm so humbled thank you so much
Pennsylvania's Democratic Lieutenant
Governor John fetterman overcame any
doubts about his stroke recovery with a
narrow victory over television Dr mehmed
Oz this Senate raised one of the
tightest and most watched this campaign
has always been about fighting for
everyone who's ever been got knocked
down that ever got back up
the Keystone states Democratic attorney
general Josh Shapiro nabbed the
governor's race handily defeating
trump-backed Republican and 2020
election denier Doug mastriano who
refused to concede we're gonna have
faith and have patience we're going to
wait till every vote counts right when
they're finished counting the votes from
today's election
that we're going to have received more
votes than my opponent we know that
down in Georgia incumbent Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock barely outpelled
football star and GOP Challenger
Herschel Walker and because neither is
above 50 percent Georgia law mandates a
runoff which is now expected for
December 6th we're in a fight are we not
are we in a fight
Republican and trump-backed JD Vance
took a key open senate seat in Ohio
triumphing over Democrat Tim Ryan I have
the privilege
to concede this race to JD Vance
because the way this country operates is
that when you lose an election
you concede in Wisconsin Senate race
it's too close to call Republican
incumbent Ron Johnson is still battling
Mandela Barnes for the win in the
razor-tight toss-up in Battleground
Arizona Democrat and former astronaut
Mark Kelly is edging ahead of Republican
Blake Masters and in the governor's race
there Democrat Katie Hobbs has an edge
over Trump loyalists Carrie Lake but
that raise might take days to decide and
lake has wasted little time in stoking
electoral doubt about some technical
issues with voting machines in Maricopa
County but officials there say every
vote has and will be counted we had a
big day today and don't let those
cheaters and Crooks think anything
different we have some races that are
hot and heavy and probably more than
former president Trump was predicting at
his rallies leading up to election day
exit polls show inflation and abortion
were top of my mind and economic
headwinds were not enough for some of
his back candidates to fend off some
pretty stiff competition including in
the house where predicted huge gains
have faded but Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis might have moved closer to a
possible 2024 presidential bid with a
commanding victory over former Governor
Charlie Chris freedom
is here to stay
also in the Sunshine State Republican
senator Marco Rubio picked up a
double-digit win over representative Val
demings in Nevada it's still a toss-up
but currently the results show incumbent
Democrat Catherine Cortez masto trailing
Republican Adam laxalt Bob thank you I
appreciate you I know you're not going
anywhere so we'll check back in with you
a little bit later